to keep diners safe restaurants around
the nation are putting social distancing
policies in place
in virginia last night one of the
nation's best known dining venues
reopened with an inventive solution in
place
diners aren't very demanding but who
still
contribute to the atmosphere ed o'keefe
has that story
world-renowned chef patrick o'connell
thinks he's figured out how to recapture
the magic of a full dining room
at the inn at little washington
customers
who don't pay or speak or
move much either this young man is
proposing to the
sweet young lady there as he's proposing
which is something that happens here a
lot
you have a sense that instead of just
sitting there
looking dumb they are
in action action is exactly what
o'connell craves
reopening has never been in doubt for
the little inn tucked at the base of
shenandoah national park
and its allure has only grown since 2018
when it was awarded three michelin stars
the only establishment in the region to
earn the top honor
but for o'connell a lifelong theater fan
an empty dining room
is an empty stage i was working in
restaurants
all during school studying theater and
i realized that living theater was where
it was at
and then i fell in love with the idea of
a dual theater the kitchen versus
the dining room you had two plays
running
or a split screen so if this is a
theatrical production the pandemic is a
hell of a plot twist
that's where the mannequins outfitted in
costumes from the 1940s by a northern
virginia theater company
come to the table everyone calling now
for
future reservations wants to come and
see them
they really mean they want to come and
see how it makes them feel
and i got to believe some customers are
going to like this because they don't
like to think that the next table over
is listening in on their conversation
exactly
exactly and it also allows our wait
staff to
top off their wine or look in on the
mannequin
or me to go out and be sure everything's
fine is it wasting wine a crime
who gets to drink that wine at the end
of the night surprisingly when we come
back in the next morning that wine is
always gone the inn at little washington
is the heart and soul of this tiny
virginia town with fewer than 150
residents
o'connell first knew it as a gas station
on family trips
but he had a vision i just thought it
was the most wonderful thing of
getting away from all reality going out
in the country and
finding some elegant
wonderful dinner his parents didn't want
him to become a chef
but a trip to europe after college only
cemented his desire to cook
i thought to myself yes i must do this
whatever it takes his instructor julia
child's famed cookbook
mastering the art of french cooking my
rule was that i would make the recipe
three times just as it was written
only then would i allow myself to
improvise
and do it my way in 1978 patrick bought
that gas station
and he's been living his dream for more
than 40 years
the inn now includes more than 20
buildings on 25 acres
a garden and some animals
i left my sanitizer in the car when the
pandemic forced o'connell to close in
mid-march
his staff of 170 shrank to about a dozen
in recent weeks just three people worked
the kitchen preparing meals for
furloughed employees
and their families when they reopen
is a matter of life and death for the
community the food and lodging tax the
inn collects
supplies 90 percent of the town's budget
while we're closed the town has no
income
and that makes reopening even more
critical it does
it does because you're affecting not
just your own staff
but all the other businesses in town the
b b's the small shops and stores
but you're funding the water system the
sewage system and every all the other
infrastructure for a small town
it's a level of responsibility that most
restaurants
don't imagine how do you think this is
going to transform how americans eat out
i think there's going to be a renewed
appreciation for whatever a restaurant
has to offer
and people are pent up
they want to get out you know there's
going to be someone out there who sees
this and thinks
that seems a little opulent for the
times no no no
i think i think the problem is the
confusion
over whether or not we're still allowed
to have
fun and i think
the era that we've entered has confused
a lot of people
in that they don't know how to act they
don't know how to be
and they're fearful not only of what
they're dealing with but of how they'll
be judged
by others o'connell is eager for his end
to once again be a place to gather
even if we must maintain a certain
distance
someone said to me restaurants might be
the final frontier of human interaction
restaurants are sort of the last
bastions of trust
and they're kind of like a new religion
a sacred place because food can't lie
you know when you put something in your
mouth
if it's wonderful or it's not and
there's no no getting around that for
cbs this morning saturday
at o'keefe washington virginia
i so agree with everything he said i
cannot wait
to eat a big sumptuous meal i
i was worried that ed wasn't getting
getting his opportunity to like partake
that there wasn't the
i mean you have to when you do a dish
you must eat it's amazing
i didn't think about that idea that
people might be worried about spending
money
on a meal like that but if you're
looking for the excuse
that town 90 percent they need that
money
there's no doubt about it if that's the
reason that you need to to have
in order to go